And now for you, Scoutmaster.
So two Eskimos are sitting in a kayak.
And they've paddled out away from the shore and they're out seal hunting and it gets very, very cold.
And so they have a little firewood with them and they decide they're going to build a fire right there in the kayak and warm up.
And it turns out it's not a very good idea because the kayak burns and they sink.
Which goes to show, you can't have your kayak and heat it too.
Listen, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'll try to do better next time.
It's podcast number 29.
Hey!
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Today, we're going to keep on with talking about troop meetings and Scoutmastership in seven minutes or less.
And then our third and final installment about the future of your unit.
And somewhere in here, I'm going to throw in a Scoutmasters minute and good email that I received.
That's a lot to do.
Let's get started, shall we?
Scoutmastership in seven minutes or less.
Dear friend of mine was an artist.
And he was a very well-known and successful artist.
And if you went to visit his studio, his studio was just a shambles.
I mean, it was a terrible, terrible mess.
Not just disorderly.
Not just, you know, a little bit of dust here and there.
I mean, books strewn everywhere.
Paints everywhere.
You know, lights not working.
I had no idea how he managed to create what he did working in that studio until I watched him do it.
But he would come up with art of penetrating simplicity and beauty in the middle of this kind of junkyard of a studio.
And there's a point during, like, a weekly troop meeting or an outing or some kind of Scout function where I look around and everything that's going on kind of looks like that studio.
I mean, it's just breathtaking disorder.
From my perspective, my youth leaders are kind of slacking off.
And adults are overstepping their bounds and interfering.
And the Scouts are kind of, meh, blandly disinterested in whatever's going on.
And it looks like it's a few seconds from falling apart or just spinning completely out of control.
And I want to put my head in my hands and walk away and never come back.
So if you've been around long enough as a Scoutmaster or a Scout leader of any kind, you know the feeling.
It doesn't seem how ever carefully you prepare, however you put things together.
Your plans end up going awry and things just look horrible.
But in those moments, try and go back to my artist friend's studio.
And I imagine him laboring over a painting.
I mean, there's water everywhere.
It's pooling on a tabletop where he's working.
It's on the paper.
There are huge globs of color.
There's brushes flying and splashing.
And it looks absolutely chaotic.
But he taught me that what seemed like a mess was actually the process of creation.
He showed me there were forces at work that no one could control and nobody really wanted to control.
I mean, art came out of working within this kind of creative maelstrom.
And in understanding and cooperating with the forces in play, not in controlling it.
And I think that's the same way that it goes for Scouting.
Now we're talking about this in the context of troop meetings.
There are plenty of forums out there to talk to you about what goes into a troop meeting and who does honor patrols and service patrols and things like that.
But you need to have the broad underlying concepts of what should be happening.
That's more important to me than giving you forms and, you know, giving you an ABC on how to present a troop meeting.
The Scoutmaster's job is to set things in motion, to encourage, to exhort, inspire, and then let those things go to work.
What I see as messy and disorganized is experienced by my Scouts is just perfectly orderly and enriching.
It's just a trick of perspective and age and experience.
Now, I know that, you know, if you take some lumber and some glue and shellac and you throw it in a cement mixer, you're not going to produce a Chippendale chair.
Well, I guess theoretically you could, but we're not going to waste our time trying, right?
I'm not recommending we promote disorder or we look at it cavalierly, but rather that we recognize what looks like a real mess, what looks like real chaos, analyze it a little bit.
And within that, you might see that kind of school of character, that school of experience happening, that kind of, as I said, that vital maelstrom of creation.
There's times we have to step in and there's times that we really shouldn't because our Scouts need the same experiences that we have had in making mistakes and in coming up short or in creating successes and in doing wonderful things for themselves.
They need that same kind of experience and it's not up to us to go in and to fiddle with the knobs all the time and try and make things just perfect.
So that's one aspect of a troop meeting that I think, you know, it would be helpful for you to look at in a different light.
What you see as chaos, what you see as disorder, what you see as bland and uninteresting, your Scouts are getting an awful lot out of it.
It's something that they've planned and they've put on and that is the real value in it.
That's the real value in it.
We're going to expand on the theme a little bit in the next podcast, talking about troop meetings and the broad underlying concepts that control what goes on in a troop meeting.
We're going to expand on the next podcast.
That's right.
It's time for a Scoutmaster's Minute.
Somebody once asked Baden-Powell, the founder of Scouting, what he meant by the motto, be prepared.
They said, well, be prepared for what?
And he said, yeah, any old thing, just about anything.
Now, we usually think of being prepared as, you know, we need to have the knowledge and the skill and the gear to meet any challenge that we do as Scouts and in the broader context of what we do in life.
But just think about in the context of Scouting, about being prepared.
And we may think that we only hurt ourselves by not developing the skills or obtaining the knowledge or having the right gear in Scouts if we're camping or doing something like that.
If a Scout is too lazy or a Scout leader is too lazy or inattentive to be prepared, he becomes a burden.
He asks everybody else to make up for his selfishness and for others to bear his responsibility.
That's why we want to be prepared.
If the meeting time rolls around and the patrol leader is unprepared, he's being irresponsible and he's being disrespectful of his patrol and his patrol members.
When night falls and a Scout has no flashlight because, you know, he couldn't find it at home and he didn't want to bother, he's placing the responsibility for himself on his fellow Scouts.
Scouting develops individuals by inspiring personal responsibility and interdependence.
No one will refuse to help a fellow Scout when it's needed.
And we depend on the support of others when we make mistakes, but we should not become dependent on others to compensate for our lack of preparation.
Being prepared isn't simply about our comfort.
It's not about our personal comfort and safety.
It is respect for the comfort and safety of those who are injured.
Have you ever wandered lonely through the woods?
And everything that feels just as it should
You're part of a life there
You're part of something good
If you've ever wandered lonely through the woods
Well, we're back talking about the future of your unit
And this is the third in a series
And we're going to ask our, and try to answer our second question
Which is, who are your key unit leaders for the next five years?
Well, typically, Scout units change key leaders
Maybe three to five years
Maybe five to six years
You know, there's not a hard and fast rule there
But that's about what it seems
Anyone in a leadership position
Especially the key positions
A Scoutmaster, Cubmaster, Venture Crew, Advisor
Should have their eye on a suitable replacement
Responsible, outgoing leaders
Should see that there's a clear plan in place
For those who will take on their positions
I would say
This is more of a difficulty
Often in Cub Packs than it is anywhere else
Because Cub Packs
A boy begins Tigers in the first grade
And he'll be there through
The end of his fifth grade year
So we're talking about, you know, at a maximum
About five years
And most of the people who are going to be involved in Cub Packs
Are doing an awful lot of work
Whether you're a Cubmaster
Or a den leader
It's a lot of work
And so
They're not going to stay much past
That five or six years
Sometimes families with a couple of sons
You'll get people who will hang around a little bit longer
But this big leadership change
Seems to happen
At least in my experience
A lot more in Cub Packs than it does in Scout Troops
So here's what I want to suggest
If you know that there's a leadership change coming
If you know that
Well, I'm going to stay on as Scoutmaster
I'm going to stay on as Cubmaster
For the next two years or three years
Or something like that
And I think it's a good idea
When you take the position
To make a commitment for X number of years
Then several months prior
Or a year prior to the change
The next Cubmaster
The next Scoutmaster
The next Venture Crew Advisor
And the outgoing leader
Should be working together
And they should be training new leaders
Before they're actually in the position
And they need to observe the outgoing leader
Actually doing the job
And that's the best training there is
Now, I want everybody to avail themselves
Of all the training
That is possibly available
You know, all the online training
All the courses that you can get
It's well worth it
But actually observing a competent leader
Doing the job
Is probably the best training that you're going to get
Once it's time to hand things over
I would say a simple ceremonious announcement
To the Scouts and their families
Is in order
Preferably, you know, at a Court of Honor
Or a Blue and Gold banquet
And it's important in reassuring everyone
That the unit will continue to be healthy
And that things will go well
After the handover
The outgoing leader should remain involved enough
To advise the new leader
When advice is requested
And address any concerns that may arise
I don't think it's fair to say
Well, you know
Six months before you decide
Not to be a Cub Master
Or Scout Master
Or Venture Crew Advisor
To say, well, you know
Guys, you have six months
Find somebody
And to leave it at that
And then totally disappear
I know there's people
That are at the end of their tether
They're ready to move on
And sometimes they do it
A little less graciously
But in, you know
Looking at broad concepts
And looking at best case scenarios
We want to see
A smooth leader transition
That leaves a well-trained leader
Who knows his way around
The particular unit
In place
When that leader with some year's tenure
Is ready to move on
Not every transition is amicable
Or planned
Sometimes people suddenly quit
Or they have to be removed
From the position
For one reason or another
And they can be less than gracious
And they can cause a lot of needless drama
They may leave a key position open
With no obvious replacement in sight
And Scout units can die a pretty quick death
In those circumstances
So, you know
Even having an emergency plan
Of who's going to take over
If the current leadership
Isn't available to do things
Is pretty important
We can just avoid a lot of that unpleasantness
By making sure that we plan
And manage key leadership transitions well
Looking ahead a few years
By recruiting, training, and supporting
Potential key leaders
Is an important part
Of a stable program
Much of the time
These key leaders will be coming from
The pool of parents
Whose boys are involved in the program
But you can also look a little beyond that
My troop committee chairman
Is on his fifth or sixth year
In that position
He is a neighbor of mine
He has two very young boys
Who are not of scout age yet
But he was an Eagle Scout
And when he heard that we were involved in scouts
He expressed an interest in helping out
And he went on to become our committee chair
So he doesn't have any children involved
Which is not a bad thing sometimes
It's not necessarily concentrating
Only on the pool of parents that are available
There may be other resources within the community
That can help you out
So the next time we're together
We're going to answer question number three
Which is how does a unit reach
And maintain financial stability
That's another good one to be thinking about
When we're talking about the future of your unit
And some long range thinking
About your service to scouting
Write me a letter
Send it by mail
Email that is folks
And here's an answer to one of your emails
I like to get emails
And you can get me by email
At ClarkGreen
C-L-A-R-K-E-G-R-E-E-N
At gmail.com
And this one doesn't really need an answer
It comes from Timothy Westron
And this is what he wrote
I really enjoyed your most recent podcast
Especially the piece about
Gutzon Borglum and Mount Rushmore
If you recall
We talked a little bit about
Gutzon Borglum
And how long it took to do Mount Rushmore
And how he stuck with it
Thought it was kind of inspiring
I found it interesting
And I was pondering my track to eagle as a boy
Timothy goes on to say
I read about a boy who got his eagle at 13
At first hearing he had earned it that quickly
Shocked me and gave me cause for concern
That isn't a lot of time
To get a great deal out of scouting's experience
And what's more
I was worried that achieving so lofty an aim
So quickly would diminish
The value of scouting for the boy
But I'm glad I continued reading
The boy went on to earn more merit badges
Several eagle palms
And continues to serve as an assistant scoutmaster
In his troop
While being involved in college athletics
I was amazed at this boy's story
I've known a number of people
Who seemed destined to get to the so-called mountaintop
And claim their rank of eagle
Yet I saw so many who seemed so much better and stronger
Than I was at the time
Lose interest
Age out or just plain drop out
And I never could quite understand why
In the end
I guess that's fine
If you're enjoying the program
And getting to go on outings
The rank advancement may just be icing on the cake
But my track to eagle never seemed assured
And it was achieved only bit by bit
I earned eagle two months
Before I would have aged out
The journey was long
And there were plenty of bumps in the road
For me it was an endurance race
And in the end
It wasn't a sprint at all
Looking back
At the four scouts
Who joined at the same time as I
I was the only one
To attain the high honor of eagle
You wouldn't have guessed it
Seeing me as a new scout
Other guys seemed much more likely
To make that long track
Yet somewhere
You know
Near the end
They ran out of gas
So when you mention sculpting
Like that at Mount Rushmore
It made me think about
How my journey to eagle
Didn't happen overnight
But bit by bit
With many long hauls
In the middle
Thank you for that story
It meant a lot to me
And that's
Timothy Western
From Hinton, West Virginia
Thank you, Timothy
It's always good to hear from people
And I think folks
Will find that
That reflection inspiring
That's why I wanted
To put it on here
Remember you can email me
Clarkgreen
C-L-A-R-K-E-G-R-E-E-N
At gmail.com
Well thanks for joining us again
Here at the Scoutmaster Podcast
You can read the Scoutmaster blog
At scoutmaster.typepad.com
And you can follow us
At the Scoutmaster blog
On Facebook
And ScoutmasterCG
On Twitter
You can subscribe to the Scoutmaster Podcast
On iTunes
And when you do
Please feel free to leave a comment
Or a review
Or a rating
That's always appreciated
Kind of
Helps us figure out
What we're doing right
And what we're doing wrong
Once again
I'll remind you
You can email me
Clarkgreen
With your comments
And questions
At Clarkgreen
At gmail.com
At C-L-A-R-K-E
G-R-E-E-N
At gmail.com
Well we don't want to leave
Before we read the disclaimer
And here it is
The Scoutmaster blog
And the Scoutmaster Podcast
Are not
No, no, no
They are not
Official publications
Of the Boy Scouts of America
And
Can you guess
They're not endorsed
Or sponsored
By the Boy Scouts of America
Nope
It's just me
Talking into a microphone
And trying to lend a hand
To Scout leaders
And perhaps
Had a bit of fun
Along the way
I get a kick out of it
And we don't want to leave you
Without
Hearing from
Our founder
Sir Robert Baden-Powell
Sir Robert
Have you anything
To tell the folks today?
Good luck to you
And good camping
Why thank you so Robert
Until next time
MR.Q anything
co precis
cę
Ten
mut
based on
enjoying
赌
把
peuvent
theoretically
отвеч
Personally
supports
With
jedoch
Sz
Thank you.